[Música]
bueno y vamos a hablar entonces con
nuestro segundo invitado el día de lo
que pasa en el sector aeronáutico esto
luego de la pandemia porque por esta
época de vacaciones de verano en varios
países del hemisferio norte estamos
acostumbrados a ver huelgas y paros
tanto de los trabajadores de cabina y el
personal en tierra que elabora dentro de
los aeropuertos la más reciente ha sido
la huelga de tripulantes de cabina de
ryanair que mantiene actualmente a cerca
de 1900 tripulantes de cabina en
operativos el objetivo de esta huelga en
particular es conseguir que la compañía
aérea retomen las negociaciones del
primer colectivo para los tripulantes de
cabina en españa' a esta protesta se
sumaron sus colegas en parís produciendo
afectaciones en operatividad del
aeropuerto charles de gaulle el
principal de la capital francesa y es
que además como estamos hablando tras la
pandemia de coronavirus y luego de la
reactivación de las aerolíneas se tratan
de sortear dos prioridades la primera la
dificultad de volver a contar con todo
el personal necesario para poder operar
con normalidad tanto en el aire como en
el aeropuerto
la segunda los altos precios de los
combustibles consecuencia de la guerra
en ucrania para hablar entonces de este
tema quiero saludar a nuestro segundo
invita bless peter cétera vicepresidente
para las américas de la asociación
internacional de transporte aéreo
gracias peter por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 muy buena
mañana de martes le pregunto el estado
general de la aviación post pandemia
bueno estamos viendo primeramente el
buenos dias raúl y las deportes de medio
programa la buenas noticias es que hay
una recuperación muy fuerte dentro de
nuestro sector hay una demanda muy
fuerte por los consumidores después de
23 años con una pandemia la gente tiene
una necesidad quiere viajar quieren
volver a hacer sus vacaciones volver a
ver a sus familiares el tema de negocio
también muy importante y lo que estamos
viendo es que alrededor de todo el mundo
los países están abriendo están abriendo
sus fronteras están eliminando las
restricciones de viaje y esto obviamente
tiene está teniendo un impacto bastante
importante en en algunas partes del
mundo no en todas sobre todo en europa
en norteamérica donde si estamos viendo
pues una saturación importante hacia los
vuelos que está afectando negativamente
a los pasajeros
claro twitter también me pregunto
digamos por qué estas huelgas saciedad
en estos meses de vacaciones en varios
de los países del mundo digamos julio de
agosto como tradicionalmente
desafortunadamente pues muchas veces
esta huelga si se han tomado en lugares
en euro meses de junio julio agosto
normalmente excepto en este tipo de
huelgas sólo se ven más en europa y
obviamente eso lo está ayudando en estos
momentos donde la cadena de valor dentro
del sector de el turismo y el transporte
está negativamente afectado a raíz del
cob y la industria se está viendo
negativamente afectada por una falta
personal la industria en este momento la
recuperación para poder reiniciar lo que
son las operaciones se están viendo
dificultadas
por la falta personal que estamos viendo
que no han vuelto al sector han decidió
emprender otros en otras industrias y no
volver a la industria del transporte y
del turismo y eso está teniendo ese
impacto que no se puede
cumplir con toda la demanda que se está
viendo y por eso muchas líneas aéreas
tanto en norteamérica como en europa se
están viendo obligadas a reducir el
número de vuelos que se pueden ofrecer
durante estas fechas claro peter y le
pregunto digamos una de las razones por
las que no vuelven este personal que
trabajaba tanto en aerolíneas como en
los aeropuertos vemos en las huelgas que
ellos piden mejoras laborales mejores
salarios es decir el sector aeronáutico
como tal no está en tan buenas
condiciones laborales como para que
todas estas personas que se fueron
regresen nuevamente a trabajar en él
bueno yo creo que la industria es muy
competitiva pero también es una
industria
con muchas presiones es una industria
que requiere muchos recursos y cuando la
cadena de valor se ve afectada pues
obviamente se ve un impacto y
desafortunadamente es el consumidor que
se ve afectado no sólo en las líneas
aéreas pero también en los servicios
aeroportuarios en lo que son los
controles de inmigración es ya lo ganás
en parte de gran problema que estamos
viendo a nivel global es la parte
gubernamental donde en la parte de
seguridad security o en el proceso en
migratorio no es personal tampoco porque
tampoco ambos han vuelto a sus
posiciones de trabajo y eso obviamente
tiene un
impacto y cuando empezamos a tener esas
presiones por toda la cadena de valor en
la parte de migratoria seguridad
aeroportuario línea aérea pues
obviamente la experiencia no va a ser
bueno para los consumidores se van a
tener que cancelar vuelos
y eso no es una buena imagen dentro de
transporte aéreo pero también en el
sector turístico hotelera servicios
también no estamos viendo negativamente
afectados por esa falta de personal por
los protocolos que siguen en vigor en
muchos países que tienen que cumplir el
sector que es muy difícil y también
entrenar a nuevos personas que están
entrando para para reemplazar esas
personas esas personas que han salido de
la industria así que sin
desafortunadamente no nos coge en una
época con mucha demanda la gente que
viaja es la época de verano en muchas
partes del mundo pero nos estamos viendo
afectadas con la falta de personal claro
twitter también hablemos de otro
problema y es la guerra en ucrania que
como sabemos ha afectado a todo el mundo
y evidentemente en todos los sectores
esta guerra en ucrania ha afectado
directamente al sector aeronáutico
digamos por ejemplo con el precio de los
combustibles por las nubes ha tenido un
impacto muy importante no sólo el coste
de combustibles que en estos momentos
para muchas líneas de ellas entre 35 y
el 50% del costo operativo total de una
línea aérea así que es un coste muy
importante que se está viendo
día a día subiendo los precios y para la
mayoría de los países la línea de ellas
que no tienen moneda estadounidense se
ven negativamente impactados porque la
moneda no es tan fuerte y tiene que
pagar el combustible en dólares y
también la parte de carga que ha sido
tan importante durante estos tres años
lo estamos viendo negativamente
impactados porque tanto ucrania como
rusia o hagan un rol muy importante en
el sector carguero con la cantidad de
piezas que tenían en ese es necesaria
así que también en la parte carga no
estamos viendo negativamente impactados
en transportar las mercancías que los
consumidores quieren recibir a tiempo